[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liviana valencia aquí vamos una mirada
en profundidad los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
cada 25 de mayo se celebra el día de
áfrica también conocido como el día de
la liberación africana una fecha creada
para aumentar la visibilidad del
continente y resaltar los aspectos más
importantes de los 55 países que lo
componen hoy les presentamos un capítulo
especial este importante conmemoración
tiene su origen en la creación de la
organización para la unidad africana el
25 de mayo de 1963 el último emperador
de etiopía haile selassie el promotor de
esta iniciativa quedó los terrenos para
sus instalaciones aquí les contamos la
historia
y en el marco del día de áfrica y del
material esencia africana en colombia se
realiza la muestra itinerante de cine
africano wickham organizada por la
fundación otro surco del apoyo de la
embajada de francia clásicos y externos
del cine afro hacen parte de este
festival iniciamos entonces con la
información aquí en áfrica siete días y
conmemorando el día de áfrica con la
radiografía general del continente dado
que el objetivo de esta fecha es
aumentar la visibilidad de áfrica y el
conocimiento acerca de su historia y su
actualidad lejos de los imaginarios
tradicionales áfrica es un continente
que sirve de sustenta el origen de la
humanidad también es un territorio
innovador y dinámico con la población
más joven del planeta los países
africanos se destacan en el desarrollo
de nuevas tecnologías así como en
industrias como el cine y la moda a
continuación les mostramos algunos
aspectos de interés acerca del
continente
áfrica tiene una superficie de 30
millones 221 mil 535 kilómetros
cuadrados y cuenta en la actualidad con
55 países soberanos dos territorios
dependientes y 11 territorios integrados
en estados no africanos el país más
joven de áfrica y del mundo es sudán del
sur que se constituyó en 2011 y etiopía
es el país que nunca puede esclavizado
ni colonizado el país más grande del
continente es argelia con 2 millones 381
mil 741 kilómetros cuadrados pero el más
poblado es nigeria con más de 180
millones de habitantes y justamente los
países que concentran el mayor
porcentaje del producto interno bruto
continental son nigeria y sudáfrica
en total el continente africano tiene
una población de más de 1300 millones de
personas el norte del continente
concentra la población mestiza de
mayoría árabe mientras que la población
negra se ubica en el áfrica
sub-sahariana al menos tres mil culturas
más de 1500 idiomas y variedad de
religiones
el áfrica el continente más diverso del
mundo no solo en poblaciones sino en
recursos naturales y minerales como las
esmeraldas el oro el coltán
el platino los diamantes entre muchos
otros el 25 de mayo se celebra el día de
áfrica para conmemorar la creación de la
organización para la unidad africana el
25 de mayo de 1963 esto a pesar de que
dicha organización fue reemplazada por
la unión africana crear el año 2001 y
que sigue funcionando hasta nuestros
días
organización para la unidad africana fue
impulsada por el último emperador de
etiopía haile selassie quien nunca
permitió que su país fuera colonizado ni
esclavizado también conocido como el
rastafari haile selassie donó los
territorios para la creación de la
organización con el objetivo de promover
la independencia de los 55 países que
hoy conforman la organización cuya sede
está justamente en addis abeba la
capital de etiopía a continuación les
mostramos la historia
la sede de la unión africana se
encuentra ahora en la capital etíope
gracias a jal islas y en 1963 el
emperador te dio terrenos y locales para
albergar la organización de la unión
africana
desde entonces los jefes de estado del
continente se reúnen allí cada año
sin razón y ha trabajado aquí durante 30
años
[Música]
el ex secretario general de la comisión
conoce la historia de la organización
como nadie
y esta es la gran sala de reuniones de
los órganos y short cam
es una sala dedicada a la conferencia de
jefes de estado y de gobierno el
objetivo de la organización de la unión
africana era fomentar la
descontaminación darle la independencia
a todo el continente en 2002 la
organización se disolvió dando paso a la
unión africana cuyos propósitos son muy
variados c-zero esta visión
12 de la frick en áfrica
su visión es hacer de áfrica una áfrica
integrada una fábrica unida
un áfrica próspera y pacífica dirigida
por sus propios ciudadanos y que tenga
una voz fuerte a fort
diálogo y ayuda mutua entre los países
africanos era el credo de haile selassie
en febrero de 2019 la organización quiso
volverlo a poner en primer plano
inaugurando esta estatua frente a la
entrada principal en el interior del
edificio una galería de retratos rinde
homenaje a los padres y héroes
fundadores de áfrica
patricio lumumba con patricio lumumba
como saben la república democrática del
congo fue asesinado pero fue quien llevó
al país a la independencia cuando el
presidente nelson mandela a quien está
dedicada a la sala del presidente del
pse darse engorde senegal dar el porsche
darse en word y senegal entre todos los
retratos el dejar ir será así este suma
importancia para él en 1963 su mediación
condujo a la firma de la carta de la
organización de la unión africana a
pesar de las diferencias entre dos
grupos con ideologías diferentes
estaban los integracionistas y los
gradualistas los que querían un
continente unido un gobierno de los
estados unidos de áfrica inmediatamente
encabezado por un coma y por otro lado
los graduales dirigidos por félix su fe
juani de costa de marfil en el grado de
lista de alerta
wang y felix hufue buañi de contigua
addis abeba la capital del país
desde la caída del negros en aquel
entonces había alrededor de 900 mil
habitantes hoy en día hay más de 3
millones pero el legado de haile
selassie es cada vez más visible este
vídeo transmitido en la plaza mezcla en
el centro de la capital invite a
sumergirse en el pasado del país el
antiguo palacio de haile selassie ahora
es la sede de la universidad y a
propósito de la conmemoración del día de
áfrica que coincide con el mes de la
herencia africana en colombia y panamá
la fundación otros organiza la muestra
itinerante decide africano este año se
realiza la cuarta versión con el apoyo
de la embajada de francia en colombia
este año al igual que en 2020 la muestra
y dante de cine africano se realiza de
manera virtual debido a la pandemia de
kobe 19 y durante esta última semana
realiza una serie de conciertos en
directo por medio de su página de
facebook además de la posibilidad de
disfrutar de algunos de los mejores
títulos del cine africano clásico y
contemporáneo fue la importancia de este
evento hablamos con adrianza agregado
regional de cooperación audiovisual
de la embajada de francia en colombia
la muestra itinerante de cine africano y
wickham es un elemento original dirigido
al público de diferentes ciudades en
colombia presenta una selección de
películas africanas y sobre la
africanidad de diversas temáticas y
géneros que incluyen desde el trailer al
documental el drama histórico y la
ciencia ficción la muestra está
orientada a desafiar y nutrir en el
imaginario sobre este continente para
resaltar la versatilidad creativa de sus
directores este año la muy que hace un
viaje intercontinental que a través ya
el pulso urbano de nigeria y el desierto
de sumario' pasando por el renacer del
cine en sudán y por las inesperadas
historias que emergen de un dojo de un
dojo de karate y de un ring de boxeo
sudafricano la música también viaja en
el tiempo presentando dos clásicos del
cine africano en sus versiones
restauradas y navega si hay la futura el
afro futurismo y él
realismo mágico alianzas también nos
contó acerca del trabajo de la fundación
otro sur que promueve el intercambio
cultural entre áfrica y américa latina
por medio principalmente del cine nos
entregó detalles acerca de la
importancia de este tipo de espacios
eso está organizado por la fundación
otro sur que es una organización
independiente que promueve el
intercambio cultural entre áfrica y
américa latina durante el mes de mayo
regresa a colombia la muestra itinerante
de cine africano muy 2021 en su cuarta
edición y debido a la asociación actual
por el momento la muestra fortalece y
diversifica su programa virtual con
proyecciones en línea gratuitas a través
de la plataforma bonet puntocom durante
todo el mes de mayo también se tienen
previstas siete estaciones en el país
para la programación presencial que
fueron aplazadas hasta que los
espectadores puedan disfrutar de esta
fiesta de cine africano en las salas y
espacios de proyección con plena
seguridad aún no se han definido las
nuevas fechas probablemente será en el
mes de junio
las ciudades donde podrán descubrir esas
películas son cali buenaventura bogotá
cartagena y en chocó por la primera vez
en quito nucky y el valle
desde la embajada de francia es para
nosotros un honor poder apoyar esta
muestra de cine africano y hemos
colaborado con ellos a través de un
aporte en programación con 8 películas
africanas que provienen de nuestros
fondos de la cinemática áfrica muchas
gracias y finalizamos este capítulo
especial de áfrica siete días por la
conmemoración del día de áfrica con
música de una de las artistas
contemporáneas más reconocidas del
continente se trata de jimmy al lado y
su canción áfrica
[Música]
bien
porque le tengo que ir
[Música]
en esta canción la nigeriana muestra los
hermosos paisajes africanos pero sobre
todo resalta algunos de sus líderes más
importantes varios de los cuales
participaron en la creación de la unión
africana si sencillo se ha convertido en
una de las canciones africanas más
escuchadas durante los últimos años así
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero ustedes pueden continuar
con más nuestra página web www punto
preventa y cuatro.com y allí ampliar la
información de américa latina y el mundo
quédense con nosotros es otras 24
chicas
[Música]
cavani min
después
para ver que ese sentido
[Música]
como escucha
no me escucha de cannes
hakuna matata es como una escucha culpa
kubica tensión la culpa
desde aquí
[Música]
no sé
no hay café
no mueve el acción
aguayo
no voy a abrir la cabeza